nearly 70% of Catholic Americans in the
CBS News poll say they favor letting
Catholic priests marry 25% remain
opposed the push for married priests
could become a reality
in a remote part of the Amazon if Pope
Francis agrees the Pope's been meeting
with indigenous Catholics from the
region in recent days a group of church
leaders will vote on the issue tomorrow
Seth Downes outside the Vatican with the
controversial debate set what Seth what
exactly is being discussed well the
discussion here is about the idea of
allowing so-called proven men men who
were already married to be ordained it
is a topic that has gotten the most
attention in this nearly month-long
meeting or Synod being held here at the
Vatican in which the church is trying to
discuss some of the issues they're
facing in the Amazon
among them deforestation and climate
change
indigenous people and church bishops
from the Amazon have traveled to Rome
lending an exotic flair to the Vatican
but also raising serious concerns Pope
Francis is concerned about the poor the
marginalized and these people are the
poor and the marginalized I think father
Thomas Reeves his senior analyst with
religion news service explains one major
crisis in the Amazon is the shortage of
priests there simply are not enough men
coming forward who are willing to be
celibate priest so the question the
bishops have to answer is which is more
important to the Catholic Church having
the Eucharist and the sacraments in
these places are having a celibate
clergy a lack of clergy means some
Catholics in remote areas may have
communion only once a year
Pope Francis is taking part in these
daily meetings I am so is Mauricio Lopez
who's with the Amazonian church group
reap AM is there any way to compare the
shortage of priests that you see in the
Amazon with some place in America well
it's like having probably two priests
for the whole state of Oregon no
accessibility by roads but by rivers
sometimes or not having the possibility
to get there but through private
airplane which you cannot afford its
these details they're trying to make
clear to the Pope this is no Parliament
we are not taking votes to the side we
are helping him to understand what's
happening to get the inputs that he
needs and he'll be the one ultimately
making the decision do you think we'll
see married priests in the Catholic
faith I think we will I think there's a
good chance we're gonna have it
this Pope recognizes that Salomon see is
just the rule and he likes to break
rules when yes Father Reese reminded us
that about a thousand years ago Catholic
priests could be married st. Peter the
first pope was married and some Catholic
branches allow it today there is
division in the ranks you're certainly
hearing from bishops who say this is a
slippery slope yeah I mean not in
to some extent I agree with them I mean
once you allow married clergy in the
Amazon what can you say no to parts of
Asia or Africa or even the United States
now this is just a recommendation that
is being voted on tomorrow ultimately it
is all up to the Pope and Tony he can
decide to speak with other bishops and
he can take as long as he'd like which
starts in the Amazon may not stay there
though Fred thank you very much